hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen zurück bei easyjet heute aus
dem wunderschönen bratislava
bei uns ist jana hannah hallo karin du
kommst du aus bratislava und du lernst
deutsch warum ich habe viele freunde in
deutschland in der schweiz in österreich
noch nie gemacht mein deutsch verbessern
dabei helfen wir doch jetzt ja nachricht
jetzt zusammen mit uns hätten die leute
auf der strasse interview wir suchen mal
ein paar deutsche und österreichische
touristen und fragen sie was sie an
dieser stadt um diesem wunderschönen
land lieben
los geht's
was macht er in bratislava
wir machen zwei wochen urlaub und machen
da einen ganz ganz kleinen stopp in
bratislava für ein tag
wir haben es gerade die stadt angeschaut
und waren oben auf dem schloss und die
donau angeguckt von da superschön
hallo hallo was magst du in bratislava
ich studiere hier denkt man in
deutschland über bratislava andere
städte kennt man manchmal mehr
also es ist ein bisschen so die 70 ganze
welt wenn man so viel weiß eigentlich
wenn wir anderen davon erzählt haben wo
wir hinfahren haben wir meistens
bukarest gesagt bei bratislava ist weiß
ich nicht
hört man nicht so häufig was waren sie
schon mal in der slowakei nein nein noch
nie
nein das erste mal ja das erste mal und
eben auch nur für ein paar stunden so
lange wie das schiff hier liegt sie in
deutschland was denken die deutschen
über die slowakei ich weiß gar nicht
also ich glaube nicht dass die slowakei
als land sehr bekannt ist und von daher
weiß ich kann ich nicht sagen was die
leute denken also das ist einfach man
weiß dass das land gibt glaube ich
was denkt ihr denn was denken deutsche
über die slowakei keine ahnung
das ist mal einen teil von tschechien
war wie haben sie dann aber deswegen
sind wir ja auch hier was magst du an
bratislava ich mag in bratislava vieles
ich bin ehrlich gesagt sehr überrascht
weil in deutschland ist es bratislava
slowakei überhaupt nicht bekannt also
man kennt natürlich man weiß dass es das
land gibt sowie eine frau in der episode
heute gesagt hat aber man weiß gar nicht
wie das aussieht also wir haben keinen
bild im kopf
so was habe ich mag die altstadt mit den
alten gebäuden und auch dass viele das
gute leben mit den vielen kneipen und
restaurants ja mir gefällt die altstadt
sehr schön es ist sehr sauber die häuser
sind sehr schön aus und das wetter ist
natürlich hervorragend was habe ich
gerne in bratislava also allgemein finde
ich die stadt sehr schön
obwohl es etwas osteuropäisch aussehen
dann naja jeder dem ich bisher hier
besucht hat das gesagt dass er so
eigentlich nicht so hübsch sei und ich
wohne in ertrank
ja da sieht es ein bisschen weniger
hübsch aus aber nicht nicht an zustimmen
wir fahren nach budapest morgen platten
sehe dann sage slowenien italien noch
eine ecke und dann geht's wieder nach
hause
brachial mini mini tipp wie fahrt ihr
durch die gegend mit dem auto voll schön
sowas will ich jetzt auch folge wir sind
zwei wochen einfach nur in bratislava
haben schon gesagt ist eine schöne stadt
und ich bin total überrascht dass sie
super super schöner ist als zumindest in
der innenstadt hier wo wir auch eine
eher wohnung kam für zwei wochen und ihr
gewohnt haben und diese es ist alles so
wie eine filmkulisse habe ich gesagt es
sieht alles perfekt was es alles super
schön die gehäusen superschön und diese
atmosphäre dass leute draußen sitzen und
ein bier trinken etwas draußen essen das
finde ich total nett das hast du in
deutschland fast nirgendwo in berlin ein
bisschen weil es auch sehr international
ist im süden ein bisschen aber ansonsten
deutschland ist viel drinnen und hier
ist viel draußen gefällt mir total sonst
gefällt mir also man kann ja schön viele
sachen machen die berge sind auch wir
trinken kann man hier ganz gut also ist
gefällt mir ganz gut und was überrascht
euch bisher eigentlich nichts
bisher ist es so wie wir es erwartet
haben wir schon dass es hier so
wahnsinnig geil aussehen
wir sind recht viel unterwegs und wir
haben
bratislava vielleicht in so eine
schublade geschoben aber es stimmt halt
mit der schönen altstadt zum beispiel
geheimtipp naja also sicher einfach mal
die schönen sowjet bauwerke anzukommen
ist wahrscheinlich kein geheimtipp aber
zum beispiel zum beispiel gibt es hier
eine bahnstrecke
keine bahn mehr fährt und da kann man
hingehen dass es zwischen dem
hauptbahnhof und moskito na ja viele
leute gehen so von punkt zu punkt und
hören sich alles an mit einem tourguide
das ist so gehe ich normalerweise nicht
in eine stadt sondern ich mag das ein
bisschen zeit zu verbringen einem café
zu sitzen menschen zu beobachten mit
menschen zu sprechen was wir jetzt zum
beispiel machen das ist mein tipp
überhaupt wenn man irgendwo anders hin
fährt versuchen das leben kennen zu
lernen und nicht nur fünf kirchen
angucken wo kommt er her
sie kam als team aus wien erst mal ein
ort ist ja doch so nah dann muss man
noch öfter hinfahren ja aber wir sind
durch evinger oper und ich kann
eigentlich aus deutschland und den
vereinigten wo bist du in deutschland
aufgewachsen stadtkasse und war das ein
großer eine große veränderung zwischen
stuttgart und wien
ja die leute zum anlass von der
mentalität sowie sind sie drauf sind die
offener oder ein bisschen
zurückhaltender und lätta gibt es
irgendwas hier was zu sagen das hast du
noch in keinem andern land das alle
studenten immer am wochenende nach hause
fahren ihren eltern was machst du am
wochenende ja ich bin bei der nicht zu
den
ja liebe leute das war unsere episode
aus bratislava wir hoffen es hat euch
gefallen wir hoffen ihr habt etwas von
dieser wunderschönen stadt gesehen und
viel darüber gehört danke dass du dabei
warst danke und wir wünschen dir noch
viel erfolg beim deutschland- und euch
natürlich auch wenn ihr es habt uns zu
unterstützen und auch ein paar outtakes
zu dieser episode zu sehen dann könnt
ihr das hier unten machen wir patchen
und abonniert natürlich isar germany
damit ihr nächster woche wieder dabei
sagt danke fürs zuschauen und bis bald
tschüss